[Música]
Precisamente en directo Ah nos vamos
hasta Guatemala porque este lunes se
llevó a cabo la primera audiencia de
imputación de cargos en contra del
reconocido periodista José Rubén Zamora
director y fundador del diario el
periódico uno de los medios que más ha
revelado escándalos de corrupción en los
que estaría involucrado el presidente
Alejandro giamatey para abordar este
tema conectamos con nuestro corresponsal
en Centroamérica Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
Andrés buenas noches para usted que
cargos le fueron imputados a José Rubén
Zamora y que tuvo de particular esta
audiencia en la que se incrimina a uno
de los periodistas más críticos del
gobierno
Hola Ángela buenas noches para usted
también bueno Fueron cuatro cargos los
que le imputaron a José Rubén Zamora hoy
en la audiencia que tuvo en los altos
tribunales aquí pues en ciudad de
Guatemala lavado de dinero chantaje
tráfico de influencias y conspiración y
quizás el momento más impactante de esta
audiencia que se llevó a cabo en este
juzgado fue cuando la fiscalía presentó
la evidencia de un sobre que contenía
300.000 quetzales hablamos de un
promedio de 40 mil dólares que habría
sido el dinero que presuntamente lavó
este reconocido periodista guatemalteco
el pasado 19 de julio en su defensa él
dice que es un dinero que corresponde a
un préstamo completamente legítimo
lícito y de hecho culpa a los diferentes
gobiernos guatemaltecos de una
persecución política en contra del
periódico y de haber estado en contra
intimidado a sus anunciantes que son
quienes le dan la Pauta publicitaria
para que este medio de comunicación
prospere sin embargo lo que dice la
fiscalía es que es un dinero lavado y
habría sido a través de la figura de un
ex director de banco un testigo clave
una persona que desde el 2018 tenía
congelada sus cuentas con más de 30
millones de quetzales hablamos de 4
millones de dólares pero ahora que es
testigo clave pues le fueron nuevamente
devueltos estos dineros la audiencia
sigue adelante este es uno de los cargos
pero desde ya familiares y amigos dicen
que este es un caso de un preso político
y vayamos un poco de contexto cinco días
antes de la captura de José Rubén Zamora
fue publicado en el periódico un
artículo una columna en la que se
relaciona el presidente llama ti con el
que sería su pareja sentimental y que
para muchos o fue el detonante de la
criminalización de este periodista de
qué se trata
Así es Ángela a sus 66 años Alejandro
yamatey es un presidente separado con
tres hijos de derecha en contra
abiertamente del matrimonio homosexual
sin embargo se ha vuelto vox populice
popularizado aquí en Guatemala que se
hable de las relaciones sentimentales
que tiene el presidente y justamente en
esta fábula que publicó el periódico
cinco antes de ser capturado su director
se habla de la relación de los dos
Miguel Martínez sería El Principito azul
y Alejandro yamatey el ogro en la
relación de estos dos habría hecho que
Guatemala sea un país que esté en
desgracia por cuenta de un gran desfalco
por cuenta de una estafa y es por esto
que se dice que presuntamente este
periodista está capturado y está siendo
criminalizado